all right shaylyn
Shaylin where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
um I'm from Naples Florida born and
raised and tell me about your family
um
so I had like a really good stepdad
until
um
my mom and him divorced but other than
that she had like a few marriages and
really it was just us and our mom
um she had like you know drug addiction
issues and your mom did I don't know
think she ever like experienced it to
the severity that I'm experiencing it
now
she always kind of kept it together
enough for us to have like a roof at
least she didn't have fentanyl oh she
well back in that time it was just the
doctor shopping with the um blues and
stuff right so fennel hadn't hit the
streets and she never really did heroin
um I think she shot up maybe for like a
week and that was like her Breaking
Point
so we surpassed that I used to be really
angry at her but now I'm just sad that I
wasted a lot of time angry did your mom
eventually get clean she's been clean
for seven years she works as a nurse and
a home nurse for like schizophrenic
patients well
how old are you I'm
27 28. honestly I don't know
28 Maybe 94.
28.
yeah introduced to hard drugs as hell
and when
um
whenever I was divorcing my husband we
got married at 16 and 18 and you know I
didn't think ahead and stuff but when we
were getting divorced we hadn't been
separated in the system legally yet so
he took my child one night and didn't
come back and
I didn't see my kid for like seven
months
and um
so in that time in order to sleep and I
mean I felt like my kid was kidnapped
and the cops want to help nobody would
help I didn't know where he was or what
was happening to him I didn't know
anything and um his dad wouldn't speak
to me and I just felt like I was nobody
was helping me and my son was kidnapped
you know even though I can't say that
because he wasn't as his dad
but you know it was just the way the
croaky crumbled I was just
that was legal so I couldn't sleep I
cried every night and
I did this drug one night and I sniffed
the smallest out of it and I forgot I
was sad and had a great night and was
able to like push that down you know
and um I started doing it a lot and I
finally had gotten an emergency pickup
order to pick up my child I got him back
from his dad
we then had to go through Court to do
anything
um
and I eventually had one full custody
but all of this I did while hooked on
drugs so when I did win the full custody
my brother came and he
took my son so that I could go to
rehabbing it clean and
I did do that it was working for a while
somehow I relapsed you know I was like a
chronic relapser they say
so your first the first Hard Road you
tried was first hard drug I've tried was
cocaine at 16. but all of that stuff
didn't affect me until heroin when I
first sniffed heroin
it was like the love of my life I was so
happy like to find this thing I felt
like I was self-medicating like my whole
life I was bipolar I couldn't control my
emotions couldn't sleep and in my head
even though everyone else sees me
nodding out I thought like wow I finally
cured bipolar disorder and if I could
just
do a little bit every day and manage it
then I could get through life I had
energy I went to sleep
I didn't
think about my messing size
I I'm not really sure I was always
diagnosed bipolar but lately I feel like
I have like
uh borderline personality like disorder
Tendencies and
when I got high I have since the PTSD
that I've like endured I have like
schizophrenic Tendencies I mean I
wouldn't say like I'm seeing things and
hearing voices but I'm so paranoid and
so like
traumatized I guess that sometimes
it's like a rational the fear that I
have what drugs are you using at the
your fentanyl um I do Fentanyl anything
else
um I was I had to clear and um
yeah that stuff made me just pull blown
like schizophrenic so I couldn't do it
because I'm already like you know
freaking out every every time somebody
who speaks a different language I think
they're gonna traffic me every time
someone walks out of a room I think
they're talking about me if I'm in a
space with a man only
and he's from the streets and like any
second I'm gonna get raped
um I'm afraid of you know if those
things all happen to you in one way
um basically yeah
um you know like watch my friend get
beat with
AK-47s I watched her almost get
trafficked I almost got trafficked I
mean her ex-boyfriend was mad at her and
that was enough for him to send some
people after her to try to traffic her
like it's just at least like another
dimension third world country sometimes
how long have you been in L.A
um two years I took a break and went uh
to Colorado Wyoming and Alaska I went
and did like a little vacation there
after I was like kidnapped you know
um and then for some reason I came back
here because I was like I'm not gonna
let the drugs get to me
um I had fully detoxed myself and I was
like I'm gonna go be an artist like I
originally said
and no time you know back on the street
because
cost of living is so expensive and I
just came out on a whim I always do
there's no plan
so I get here and I'm like now what
where do you stay now
oh
like I said whatever my friend's not out
for the night
you know so you just crash where you can
yeah actually I don't sleep so much that
lately I've been um
I just fall and hit the cement like
while I'm standing up and then I'll
start crying and telling everybody like
I need to go to sleep you know
because like nobody listens to me when
I'm like I haven't slept in four or five
days it's like totally natural to people
out here and for me it's torture you
know I haven't shouted in three weeks
like I
like kind of roll the dirt off my skin I
guess
got me in such a bad place
patiently what would you go through
emotionally live in this lifestyle
like I miss my son and when I'm doing
things sometimes I'm like
my son doesn't care about my girlfriend
out here who has a kidney stone like
he's wondering why I haven't called him
in months and I can't tell him that
morning's getting robbed every week you
know
that people are just
you know I don't know
beat me up for myself
um
I can't remember it's like a Gucci tote
that I bought myself
and then Christian
Dior person
I was beaten up and hospitalized for a
week
my first week back because they wanted
my purse
I can't tell my kid that
so my phones are
lasts about 24 hours you know
somebody two days yeah they last like
two three days and I'm lucky
my mom can't sleep at night and I'm not
sleeping at night and my whole family
thinks I'm gonna die out here
do you have any friends
I wouldn't call any of these people my
friends
I have Associates
some of them are nicer than others but
no I would not sit down at a table and
eat dinner with any of these people
it's I'm sure they're different people
and they're clean as well but
we're living in animalistic lifestyle
those people would do
anything for a come up like if they were
at my house and my family
something happened like they would run
through their pockets before they left
you know instead of calling that another
one those are the type of people that
exist out here
who do you credit most for your being in
this situation now is it your borderline
or bipolar Tendencies or is it something
you inherited from your mom
um and then I got manic right after my
I left Florida because I was in abusive
relationship with a man and then he got
arrested the day he got arrested they
get my my son to my brother because he'd
be like safer there I lost my apartment
and my car all on the same day all that
happened so I ran to Colorado and I met
a girl that was just like me
and she also got Manic and left her
boyfriend and
when we came out here you know when
you're um manic you're like I'll make
anything happen like I believe in
you know manifestation so like we were
manic I mean we made things happen like
we were in Hollywood and
it wasn't until like the drugs
and the drugs had after my best friend
died
um from Fentanyl
he only needed cocaine that was like the
worst of it and um after that I just
kind of snapped someone tried to
fentanyl me a couple times and the third
time when I woke up after they nor can
me I was really sick
and so I was like well [ __ ] it you might
as well give it to me
and um
it just makes it easier I think to not
cry about my son every day you know I
can't just sit in a corner and bawl my
eyes out every day but I also am so
hooked you know that
before I would have just left but now
it's like I gotta think I need enough
stuff to get me home without getting me
sick because last time I tried to do
that the Greyhound bus driver left me at
a random gas station
um because I was throwing up in the
bathroom
um so I need enough stuff to eat at home
without being sick so I can go and detox
I need clothes hygiene and products and
a phone to contact my mother that's it
and for some reason I can't get that
together to save my life once I you know
get my clothes then the phone's stolen
the phone I get my clothes are stolen my
friend got everything robbed off of him
at a bus stop and Goodwill wouldn't even
give him an outfit he walked back up to
our little group of people completely
naked
I had to walk through the streets
completely naked
people are cutting backpacks off of us
and
threatening me with knives and stuff and
your t-shirts and jeans doesn't mean
nothing when
someone's starting your life but
you know we don't there's nowhere to
like I mean the streets are literally
the bathroom for these people like
downtown L.A does not let you just use
the bathroom you can't just get cups of
water because you're one in a million
doing that and they have a business to
run and they removed all the mirrors so
that people can't sit there and pick in
them yet you know
I mean it's crazy there's like um some
sort of like skin disease going around
they'd called it paranoia and stuff
forever and now I'm freaking out because
there's doctors out there sampling
people's skin and paying them 100 bucks
for it because they think it's a
parasite you know so there's so much
going on in my head all the time about
like
I have to get high just to ease my brain
what are you afraid of most
my son forgetting me
from me ending up
giving up and staying and just
I can't sit still these people are like
having a good day you know and laughing
and hanging out outside like I won't
calm down until I get home or I'm on my
way home I'm afraid that I'll just they
get so annoyed with my like pessimism
because I'm sad
I'm afraid that I'll just level out with
all of them and accept this as my life
and my son would be disappointed my
whole family will I'm afraid I'll die
and break my mother's heart
I'm afraid I'll get
traffic to Turkey you know
or raped by gang members and beating
them left for dead because all these
things happen here every day
there's a serial killer out killing
white girls you know
I'm afraid I'm not gonna last oh he's
gonna kill me
how do you support yourself now
um
I
sell I used to sell a lot of drugs I
used to sell like boxes of weed and
stuff so
it's like a hundred pounds of weed and
one go you know and I still have a few
buyers but you know being on drugs as
soon as I find out that you're on drugs
they don't trust you with their money
anymore so
recently I've got a girlfriend and she
boosts and sells like vendors you know
just like stealing from the store you
know
um
I try not to do that but I do it for
like hydrogen products and stuff of
course because
food sometimes I have to somebody stole
my food stamp card
and I it took everything for me just to
go to the office the first time and sit
there and go through it because you
can't walk outside and like hit your
dope and come back in like you're there
for six hours you're gonna get sick
sitting in the chair like took
everything in me just to do it the first
time and now I have to do it again and
I just haven't gone did it you know
there's no excuse I just don't want to I
Wanna
go sit in a corner and cry I don't like
people seeing me in cars like when I'm
walking down the sidewalk
and these people they've accepted this
life they don't care
so I'm constantly finding my girlfriend
because I don't want to do these things
or I don't want to be seen and they're
all like oh you think you're better than
us and I'm like no I think we're all
better than this and
people look at me like I'm um
you know
putting them down or something because
I'm white and
the thing I think I'm better than them
but I think we're all better than this
is what it is
I mean you could tell some people are
like have a chance and you could
probably help them and they would be
okay
but some people you look in their eyes
and they're just gone gone they're on
another planet
having their own conversations with
their friends in their head you know
do you feel like your old life is
slipping away from you for sure I'm
forgetting who I was I'm constantly like
reminding people like hey I'm a nail
technician this that and then they're
like I've got a client for you and I'm
like
sorry all my stuff was stolen
but I remember just the other day I was
I was like talking to my friend and I
remember like talking how my kid talked
when I was telling her about him and I
was like I'm gonna forget how he talks
and like his mannerisms
I forget my own mannerisms because I
used to be
am I like bipolar if I was bipolar I
would have been the kind that's Happy 90
of the time
sad ten percent and now I'm just
either disassociated just not thinking
people talk to me and I don't hear it
or
um I'm sad I'm miserable so I'm
forgetting who I was you know because
that was my whole personality
you know I used to make jokes and say
certain things and like
I don't even remember who that girl is I
remember getting excited to see the
mountains in Colorado on the first time
and it was like I went on this date with
this guy and he like took me all the way
up to the mountains and showed me like
my whole Skyline lit up at night
it was like my favorite day ever and I
was so happy
and now
it's like nothing amazes me and I've
seen so much like evil in the world that
like
I don't even know if I could get that
excited because they're not happy again
if I wanted to know it all
I wanted to know everything but you
don't want to know everything you can't
take it back
I've seen some crazy stuff
um
the lowest point right now
this is the lowest point and
my life and probably any life
that I've lived if we are energy and can
reincarnate I mean this is like the
lowest point in any life I've probably
ever lived like
um my spirit is broken for sure
I don't think I even have a spirit to
break anymore I'm just I'm just existing
if that makes sense
I feel like every day I have to fight
off
old men that have money
they um feel that they can
grab me and touch me
by me and like think like whatever they
want to do they can do because they have
money and when I tell them no like I'm
not like that I don't get down like that
you know I've been like smacked I've
been threatened that's
I literally had guys look at me like
what is she talking about like you know
this is just how it is like and
like my friends like don't you guys feel
like this is rapey you know and
like weird and
they're like oh it's just how it is I
mean I don't want anybody to touch me
like ever again I I don't even know if
I'll ever have sex again the same way
like I am
it's almost like disgusting to me now
we gotta feel the same feelings I don't
know if I could ever again like
this is really shitty
I don't know if I'll ever find that girl
I used to be again
everything's so serious now
have you tried to get clean from Final
um
I think I like pretty much detox myself
in Alaska those last couple days I was
in on Suboxone
or anything so I definitely
um
was clean
um and I was only on Suboxone to get off
of
like the fentanyl I withdrawed and I was
like convulsing I mean I was like
screaming my sleep it was the worst
detox ever I swear to God I was never
gonna go through it again
but I was told to come back out here
because one of our
vendors had made a you know deal with
like Klitschko or something they were
going to be on taxes and it was going to
be all paper deal which meant is legal
and so they are supposed to be like
Vans
um to work vans they're supposed to be
four
dispensary setups and I was going to be
able to live in one of the bedrooms of a
three-bedroom apartment
when I got out here it was all a lie the
guy
literally had nothing together
um
so like
I ended up on the street
and I was so like gung-ho and convincing
everybody that like I got this and like
I had a job coming out here and I wasn't
going to use
that when it happened I just decided to
like
Exile everybody
so they didn't know you know
how bad it was
Shaylin what's your biggest regret
ever leaving my home in the first place
I left because I had a warrant out with
my arrest
and I had just gone through a whole lot
of stuff but I had family and support
there
and I think that I just thought that I
wanted to travel and see the world and I
wanted to live you know and experience
all these things and sometimes look at
my friends and I'm like you guys don't
even know you guys have been there since
high school you know I've done all these
things since then
like was it worth it I would give
anything up just have my husband and my
kid back
you know
now that I've seen the other side but
we don't get to see the other side and
then choose one you know that's the
decision I made and
so my brother's at home playing video
games with my ex-husband they're best
friends and my sons running around
doing his thing and they're all just
like a happy family and I'm just wasting
away
unfortunately
like when you just found me I was just
like begging people for a hotel voucher
like
so I could take a shower
because it's been so long
I'm deadly defeated I'm broken
for sure
when I wake up I don't even want to move
I'm just
existing in this body
till it gives out
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um it's like the grasses and greener on
the other side it's probably like fake
grass like just water your own grass
you'll be happy with it
Shaylin thank you so much for sharing
your story thank you you get your room
tonight nothing else really yeah thank
you